[Music]
hey guys its III 2018 I'm Justin hey
wolde and I'm joined by Daniel Berlin
the design director over on battlefield
5 so battlefield 5 had a lot of its news
a lot of its reveals a little bit before
e3 but now here at the show is when
we're finally getting to try it out
which which is pretty exciting yeah
definitely
so what do you do day-to-day like what
is your job on the game itself yes as
the design director my job is to set the
the general direction for for the game
in terms of in terms of the design and
then I work with the design team which
are the the true specialists within each
area to work with them to make sure that
we're staying on par with the general
direction from from the start of the
game all the way to the finish which is
really important for a game like
Battlefield 5 which is taking in some
ways a departure from both traditional
battlefields and the battlefield that we
got last year like there's a there's a
lot of new stuff in this one there's a
whole bunch of new stuff
I mean first and foremost I mean one
that had really really big things is
that we're moving away from premium
which i think is a great thing
no more segmentation of the player base
we're really building this game to be a
game about team play a game about squad
play so and if it is a game about team
planes well played then we can't have
scenarios where you're playing with your
friends and then you're gonna be joining
particular map and someone says oh I
can't join it because I don't have that
so which a removal of premium we make
sure that everyone gets to gets to enjoy
everything we we're gonna be building
for this game I guess in some ways that
might be seen as you know having that
premium experience makes you feel a
little bit more invested do you feel
like that might change that feeling at
all among players or do you think this
is gonna be a more open environment I
mean this is something that we've been
we've been requested to do for a long
time at a community so I see this as and
when we announced it I mean it was
unanimously a positive response so I'm
not worried about this decision to make
something free that's that's got to be a
little bit more exciting would you make
it more accessible exactly
and tides of war is also a really big
part of that afield 5 yeah that's what
it is I mean the types of war is this
journey we want the players to go on as
they play battlefield 5 they'll go on
the tides of war which is a journey
through the Second World War where we
will introduce players to new theatres
of war and with the introduction of the
company which is this place for you you
you you build your own company of
soldiers vehicles weaponry and as you go
through the types of oil you'll you'll
collect more vehicles you'll collect
more weapons you'll collect more
archetypes that you can play with so
you'll see how your company just grows
and how you can then just go deeper into
customization as the journey goes on so
it's it's it's a really great journey
we're taking players on there's always
gonna be some element of fantasy with
this kind of you know it's a
role-playing environment but I think
battlefield probably more than some
other war games is is a little bit more
realistic a little bit more grounded
like how much research do you guys put
into this kind of experience I mean we
put an extensive research I mean for us
it's never really about being History
Channel we don't want to be History
Channel we always say that we want to
put fun over realism but that I mean
when we go and we would choose to depict
certain parts certain locations for
example we travel to those locations we
do extensive photo scanning we we fly
remove drone so we cover big areas and
that amount of detail is also something
that we do and we're looking to the
weaponry for example we we we go on
extensive trips and we will record the
the award-winning battlefield sound by
the nvd audio team because they just
literally get to go on trips and blow
[ __ ] up that's what they do you know you
don't ever tag along with them just to
do you know shoot a few things no I
think we're too busy at the office so
but I do envy the the artists and the
the author guys to get to go on these
also trips one of the other I think big
changes for a battlefield in this
instance is the way the movement is a
little
different yes so we're taking a look at
basically the abilities of this soldier
as a whole not just a movement but
things that you how the soldier
interacts with the world basically but
so one example that I that I I keep
coming back to is in in previous
battlefield games and if you're standing
inside of a room and someone Chuck's a
grenade at you you have two choices you
the run or you die that's passive idiots
but in in in this battlefield
battlefield 5 you have multiple choices
now so if some that exact same scenario
happens to you you'll be able to rush up
to the grenade pick it up and throw it
back at the enemy or you could shoot
your grenade as it's coming at you shoot
it out of the sky or you can through a
new movement system simply just dash
forward to a window and press jump and
you will throw yourself through the
window and then execute a combat role as
you land and then just continue your
momentum forward so there's a lot more
things that you can do as a player you
can for example you can sprint while
crouching which adds a whole new layer
of tactical movement to the battlefield
where you can move quick behind
half-height cover but even those
instances when you're dashing between
cover to cover you'll actually be able
to do that while still having like a
smaller frame and of course it's not as
fast as a standing sprinting but it's
it's it's another layer of tactical
movement basically one thing that I
think got a lot of attention and
especially because it's part of the
cover is that that female fighters also
play a big role in the game there is
such a it seems a very ridiculous outcry
from fans but like that that is itself
very realistic to to that period right I
mean there were there was definitely
that I mean as you'll see in the and the
the war story that we announced which is
the nor least worst story we're actually
fighting and playing as a Norwegian
resistance fighter in the German
occupied parts of Norway but in the
general mentality that we had when we
made this decision as we look at our we
look at our player base and we see that
it's a very diverse player base there's
a lot of people that play battlefield
and battlefield has always been a game
where you can play it how you want to
play
hey you want to be in a tank you can do
that hey you want to be in the sky
flying an airplane you can do that you
want to be a medic a recon sniper it's
up to you so we took this decision and
said like hey you can play the game how
you want to play it but this time around
you can also be who you want to be so
it's about letting all our players
create the soldiers that they want to
and customize them to look the way they
want to as they build a company so you
would be able to build multiple soldiers
and those soldiers can look and play
exactly how you want and the other a bit
of controversy for any Electronic Arts
games is around loot boxes there's no
premium pass what about blue boxes this
time
so no more loot boxes there so I just
want to say like battlefield has never
been a paid to win game and battlefield
will never be a paid to win game you
will not be able to buy any type of
gameplay enhancers in that sense you
will never ever be able to pay in
battlefield 2 to base a good bait make
you unbalanced towards something else
that's not what we do it's gonna be
coming in a very crowded period near the
end of this year on ps4 Xbox one and PC
you know what's the exact date in
October October 19th October 19th so you
we're gonna have a lot of a lot of
choices for gamers always the cram that
is crazy
what what is it that makes battlefield 5
the thing that you're like this is what
you should play before you play those
others just wait for it play battlefield
5 first I think if you if you just look
at the game as it stands I mean it has
the d war stories those really untold
unseen war stories of personal stories
and we also have co-op for the first
time since battlefield 3 a couple with a
great multiplayer offering so I think
the game as a whole has so much to offer
in general and there there's so many new
gameplay additions we're completely
updating the that the dynamics of the
sandbox that is the multiplayer because
we're adding the fortification system
which makes sure that every single class
can take out the the fortification tool
and they can build they can build
sandbags they can build tank Stoppers
trenches foxholes machineguns so you can
completely
reshape the battlefield versus in the
previous installments you because we've
only been able to wreck the battlefield
but now you can actually bring it back
up again so those two systems work in
this beautiful harmony and I just think
players are gonna feel that this is a
new this is a new battlefield for them
it sounds like a lot of exciting things
to look forward to this October 13th
19th October 19th yes so a lot of things
to look forward to this October 19th and
for even more exciting things coming out
of III 2018 be sure to stay tuned to
games by calm